Since landing the role of Joi in Blade Runner
2049, actress Ana de Armas has shot into the
spotlight — leaving many sci-fi fans wondering
where they've seen her before.
After starting her acting career in Cuba,
de Armas honed her craft in Spain before making
the jump to Hollywood and English language
films in 2015.
Here's a look at why Joi from Blade Runner
looks so familiar.
Knock Knock
Ana de Armas' first widely seen English-language
role came in Eli Roth's 2015 erotic horror
film Knock Knock, in which she terrorizes,
tortures and abuses Keanu Reeves' character.
She told Screen Rant it was a role she enjoyed.
"It was so much fun just going from little
girls to pure psycho."
De Armas also enjoyed making Reeves uncomfortable
before the cameras started rolling.
"Keanu is shy and feels uncomfortable.
He's not open about talking about his life
in general.
So we were really pushing him to the limit,
playing with him and touching him and whispering
things to him before the scene.
He was REALLY uncomfortable.
It really worked."
Exposed
After ruining Keanu Reeves' life in Knock
Knock, de Armas again teamed up with the soft-spoken
actor in Gee Malik Linton's 2016 thriller
Exposed.
She told TV Daily that the Reeves taught her
a lot about the craft of acting.
"It's always very easy to be with him on set;
he always wants your work to be better."
"Keanu is a great partner.
A great actor.
A great producer in this case.
And a great friend."
Reeves also didn't hold back from heaping
praise on de Armas, telling TV Daily "When
we approached Ana with the script I was like,
please say yes.
It's a great role and she's remarkable.
I only have one scene with her at the end
of the picture, which was great, but I wish
we'd had more."
War Dogs
de Armas' big 2016 wrapped up with a supporting
role in Todd Phillips' biographical dramedy
War Dogs, in which Jonah Hill and Miles Teller
get caught up in some super shady arms dealing
while exploiting a government initiative allowing
small businesses to win U.S. military contracts
during the Iraq War.
de Armas told Orange Magazine she took the
role in part because she wanted to work with
Phillips.
"Todd is very smart and what I find so remarkable
about him is his ability to put movies together
that connect so well with audiences.
On the set, he knows what he wants and when
you feel that confidence in your director,
who is the person telling you what he's looking
for, it's amazing."
Overdrive
It's been overshadowed by Blade Runner 2049,
but you may have seen de Armas in the trailers
for Overdrive.
The fact that the two films opened on the
same weekend in October, 2017 just about guaranteed
Overdrive would be overlooked.
But that's not necessarily a bad thing, as
Overdrive has been getting terrible reviews.
The one bright spot, however, is the performance
by de Armas, who The Hollywood Reporter said
"radiates more kick-ass charisma than her
thankless sidekick role might suggest."
Hey, you can't win 'em all.
And given how many high-profile features de
Armas has already landed, she doesn't have
to, because Blade Runner 2049 looks like the
beginning of a beautiful blockbuster career.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!